bonjour Marc Seynod bonjour ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire on parlait donc tout à
l'heure de cette vigilance orange
canicule qui se poursuit dans le sud-est
dans les Alpes-Maritimes ça fait déjà
plusieurs jours et ça va même être
étendu demain est-ce qu'il faut prendre
des restrictions notamment pour les
agriculteurs de ce département il y a
des sujets il y a le sujet de la
canicule qui impose de prendre des
mesures de précaution pour les êtres
humains mais pour les activités humaines
dans la règle générale c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que la vigilance puis
deuxièmement la canicule plus le faible
précipitation peuvent poser des
problèmes en termes de prélèvement dans
la nappe ou dans les cours d'eau alors
les restrictions sont déjà en cours dans
ces départements depuis plusieurs
semaines c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'il
faut anticiper pour faire en sorte qu'on
prélève le minimum nécessaire pour un
certain nombre d'activités agricoles
mais pour que ce prélèvement ne vienne
pas obérée soit dans l'été soit dans
l'année les prélèvements pour d'autres
activités agricoles ou industrielles ou
les activités humaines évidemment leur
alimentation en eau potable on pense à
ça sinon jusqu'ici si j'ose dire les
agriculteurs étaient passés entre les
gouttes l'année de récolte française
sera plutôt bonne oui alors c'est ça
peut faire l'objet de polémique mais on
a eu on a une année qui est assez
atypique avec une inversion un peu sans
doute le produit du dérèglement
climatique on a eu plutôt des
précipitations au sud au mois de mai et
un peu au mois de juin d'ailleurs aussi
qui ont inversé une tendance en tout cas
stabiliser une tendance qui était
inquiétante liée des précipitations qui
avaient été très faibles en janvier
février et donc ça a permis de
stabiliser les choses et de faire en
sorte que la végétation puisse pousser
sans qu'il y ait besoin de prélèvement
ou en cours d'eau ou en nappe et donc
les premières tendances semblent
indiquées au nord ça a été pareil un peu
inversé ou décalé si on veut dire et
donc tout ça donne le sentiment pour
cette année alors on est vraiment sur
l'année agricole et on est vraiment sur
cette météorologie là que l'année est -
catastrophique que celle qu'on avait
connu en 2022 où l'épisode de sécheresse
avait commencé très tôt et où nous
avions eu à date la date où je vous
parle nous étions déjà au troisième
épisode de canicule non pas sur un
département mais sur plusieurs
départements les températures pour
autant s'envolent aux États-Unis en
Chine elles ont même dépassé les degré
40 dans le sud de l'Europe on est un peu
cerné par cette chaleur qu'est-ce que
vous avez voulu dire quand ce week-end
vous avez parlé d'été normal j'ai voulu
vous le dire ce que je viens de vous
dire c'est à dire qu'en terme sécheresse
de précipitation et du fait que de
l'impact sur l'agriculture
avec été plus faible cette année que que
l'année précédente alors tout de suite
naissent des polémiques et je le
regrette au fond parce que je trouve que
ça n'a pas de sens j'écoutais madame
Masson Delmotte avec qui je suis en
parfaite en parfaite accord à la fois
sur diagnostic mais elle vous a repris
sur les réseaux sociaux d'abord avec un
swing et ce matin justement on va
l'écouter sur France Info et je pense
qu'il y a une responsabilité importante
pour ceux qui sont élus qui sont qui ont
une représentation
un rôle important au niveau du
gouvernement parce que finalement il y a
les aspects aigus du changement
climatique les records les choses qui
marquent les esprits mais il y a aussi
ces aspects chroniques insidieux une
chaleur intense sans record la montée
graduelle du niveau de la mer qui
accélère on a actuellement une fonte
record monde c'est important de montrer
là où il est possible d'agir pour
anticiper ces conditions climatiques
inédites
approuver pendant oui parce que
j'ai que j'avais vu au CNR et dont
j'apprécie je dis pas pour le Conseil
national de la refondation nous avions
invoqué où elle avait évoqué ces
questions dérèglement climatiques la
vérité c'est qu'il faut il faut ne pas
être au ballotté entre ce que sont les
records de température ce qui qui
progressivement malheureusement du fait
du dérèglement climatique vont être sous
nos yeux mais d'un point de vue
structurel c'est pas le record qui va
être le plus grave le plus grave encore
que les records peuvent être des
symptômes le plus grave c'est la
tendance et la tendance c'est une
tendance globale au réchauffement non
seulement terrestre mais maritime et en
particulier cette année maritime donc
c'est là-dessus qu'il faut agir donc
j'ai pas envie de rentrer dans une
polémique d'ailleurs je crois pas que
Madame Masson Delmotte non plus mais
envie c'est pas le sujet de la polémique
personne j'espère que plus personne ne
vient remettre en cause les choses après
quand il fait 20 degrés il fait 20
degrés il fait pas 45 degrés
et la question c'est plutôt ce qu'on
fait alors deux choses dans les premiers
postes de consommation d'eau en France
c'est l'agriculture pour nous nourrir
c'est quand on dit c'est l'agriculture
c'est l'alimentation en fait puisque
quand c'est l'agriculture c'est
l'alimentation et comment on fait
d'une année sur l'autre quand on est sur
le court terme c'est qu'est-ce qu'on a
dit ce qu'on a dit tout à l'heure
c'est-à-dire comment forceur de réduire
les prélèvements quand on est sur une
tension de nappe puis deuxième élément
faut qu'on adapte notre agriculture ça
veut dire des variétés qui sont plus
économes en eau ça veut dire des
systèmes d'irrigation qui sont plus
économonaux ça veut dire parce que comme
on a une erraticité si je peux dire des
de la pluviométrie il y a des périodes
où il tombe rien puis les périodes il va
tomber 100 200 300 mm qui a autant d'eau
sur l'année mais en fait
un peu rigoureux d'un point de vue
scientifique il y a des zones de
manifestement on aura un peu moins d'eau
mais il y a des zones on aura au moins
autant d'eau et donc combien au Tandeau
ça veut dire qu'on va avoir des périodes
avec beaucoup d'eau et donc avec des
risques d'inondation et donc qu'est-ce
qu'on fait pour réserver cette eau faire
par des réserves garder de l'eau qui
sinon irait directement à la mer et
c'est pas le sujet qui est principal
pour nous le sujet principal c'est de
garder cette eau pour qu'elle puisse
être utilisée dans je sécheresse ça veut
dire des bassines agricoles c'est des
réserves de substitution la réserve de
substitution c'est quoi c'est au lieu de
prélever dans la nappe et les cours
d'eau je prends l'eau de pluie qui
ruisselle c'est quand même me
semble-t-il plus intelligent vous en
avez une sous les yeux qui est très
connu en France on pourrait l'appeler
megabassine ça s'appelle serponçon
Serre-Ponçon c'est 4000 hectares
personne ne reviendrait aujourd'hui sur
serpention parce que ça permet
d'irriguer d'amener l'eau potable plus
les activités touristiques qui est
autour mais c'est pas le sujet central
tout ça a été fait parce qu'un jour il y
a 60 ans déjà ont décidé de faire
quelque chose qui aujourd'hui sans doute
ferait l'objet de beaucoup de polémiques
donc on a besoin et pourquoi parce que
ça vient prélever de l'eau de
ruissellement bon pour vous et ça fait
agricoles
est-ce que on fait évoluer le modèle
agricole c'est pas le sujet alors faire
évoluer le modèle agricole ça veut dire
par exemple essayer de se priver du maïs
et passer à d'autres types de culture
comment on fait on paye les agriculteurs
pour qu'ils changent non mais il y a des
régions déjà où il y a une évolution sur
les assolements de maïs que les
agriculteurs ils constatent le
dérèglement climatique moi je suis le
sans doute qu'il y a des agriculteurs
qui connaissent le plus le dérèglement
les moissons sont beaucoup plus tôt les
événements climatiques sont beaucoup
plus graves c'est une des éléments de
cette année moins d'épisodes
caniculaires mais par contre des
épisodes de grêle et de tornade qui sont
plus élevés
par exemple il faut qu'on essaie d'en
remplacer par d'autres plantes de
l'alimentation alors soit pour
l'alimentation animale c'est
principalement à ça à quoi ce à quoi
sert le maïs par ailleurs le maïs
aujourd'hui il est 30% plus économe en
nous donc il faut aussi qu'on se dit ça
qu'on est des variétés qui sont plus
économes mais il demande de l'eau au
pire moment en été consomme moins d'eau
que le blé mais il en demande au moment
où il y a le moins il y a le moins d'eau
disponible et le moment où il fait le
plus chaud sans doute et donc on a
besoin de faire évoluer on peut mettre
du sorgho enfin bref il y a des tas de
de plantes qu'on peut essayer on peut
mettre du soja mais on a besoin d'aller
aussi ce qu'il faut s'éviter c'est qu'on
importe du soja du Brésil on peut aussi
avoir moins de bovins c'est ce que
réclame même la Cour des comptes en
disant ça coûte trop cher maintenant les
bovins il faut arrêter oui la Cour des
comptes disent qu'elle entend et je moi
je respecte vous m'avez pas entendu
critiquer mais je peux on peut être
d'accord avec la Cour des comptes il
faut lire ce rapport qui est intéressant
d'ailleurs en disant qu'il faudrait il y
a des zones ne faudrait plus d'élevage
alors après il y a deux recommandations
avec lequel on n'est pas en accord parce
que si le seul la seule trajectoire dans
un pays qui n'est pas autosuffisant
c'est de continuer à décapitaliser alors
ça veut dire qu'on va importer de la
viande d'ailleurs et importer de la
viande d'ailleurs ça veut dire qu'on va
apporter de la viande du Brésil
d'Australie de nouvelles Zélande est-ce
que c'est ça le modèle agricole qu'on
veut je pense que la trajectoire qui
consiste à dire par l'alimentation peut
réduire par le développement des
prairies qui stockent du carbone on peut
avoir un bilan carbone qui soit meilleur
pour l'élevage par les d'ailleurs aussi
on peut avoir un meilleur bilan et par
ailleurs on rencontre la trajectoire de
baisse de consommation de viande avec la
baisse de production et pas l'inverse il
me semble que là il y a une logique
économique écologique qui se tient sinon
sinon on déclare et en fait on n'est pas
au rendez-vous du défi qui est de
l'autre marque feno l'accord sur le blé
ukrainien prend enfin ce soir la Russie
refuse pour l'instant de prolonger
quelle serait la conséquence s'il devait
être interrompu alors c'est pas une
conséquence sur le continent européen la
conséquence c'est pour les pays qui ont
besoin de blé de céréales je trouve
d'ailleurs que beaucoup sont dépendants
des et interdépendants des échanges de
céréales et donc ça peut avoir un compte
conséquence sur le marché méditerranéen
en particulier sud du bassin
méditerranéen ça peut paraître les prix
chez nous ça peut faire nouveau chez
nous mais principalement c'est plutôt
une question de disponibilité alors
après par effet rebond ça peut faire
grimper les prix à date ils sont plutôt
stable voire en légère en légère
diminution mais j'espère que les parties
prenantes trouveront un accord c'est
sous l'égide de des Turcs que les
négociations se font nous en serions au
troisième ou quatrième épisode de
négociation abouti et c'est une
nécessité parce que c'est une
responsabilité même pour Monsieur
Poutine que de faire en sorte que les
gens dans le monde puisse se nourrir
c'est une question de stabilité c'est
une question géopolitique l'alimentation
c'est une affaire géopolitique merci
Marc feno merci ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire invité de France Info ce
matin